over a lifetime all of us change to an
extraordinary degree from a physical
perspective we start off as a little
bundle about 50 centimetres high with
cherubic features an elastic soft skin
and then we may end up some 90 years
later as a stooped gray liver-spotted
180 centimeter high structure in the
intervening period every single cell in
our body will have been replaced often
many times over and will have gone
through all kinds of experiences that
perhaps leave almost no trace in memory
the 25 year old won't remember most of
what the five year old felt so strongly
about the 67 year old will only dimly
recall what was on their mind as they
approached 30 we carry the same name
throughout our lives and consider
ourselves as a relatively stable unitary
entity but is it really right to think
of ourselves as the same person once one
puts it under a philosophical microscope
the issue of personal identity emerges
as far trickier than at first assumed so
in what ways could we be said to be
continuous throughout time what does
guarantee that we can plausibly think of
ourselves as the same people over a
lifetime just where is personal identity
located a standard assumption is that
it's our body that guarantees our
personal identity this is the theory
that a key part of what makes me me is
that I'm housed in an identical body but
philosophers like to push this
assumption around a little imagine if I
lost all my hair would I still be me yes
sure what if I lost a finger yes a leg
definitely
now what if a malevolent demon appeared
and told us that we'd have to lose every
part of our bodies but could keep just
one bit which bit would it be few of us
would pick our elbow or bellybutton
almost all of us would pick our brains
now that tells us something interesting
we assumed implicitly that some bits of
our bodies are more mesh closer to the
core of personal identity than others
and the most me shove all the bits are
our brains Christianity runs a version
of this thought experiment it asked us
to think what will happen after our
death and it imagines a separation of
the body ultimately not that significant
and the ongoing survival of a more
modest precious bit that it calls the
soul there's another version of this
thought experiment that two lovers can
play in the early throes of love to
people who've gone to bed together might
ask what do you really like about me the
wrong answer is to say you're fabulous
breasts or your amazing muscular arms
breasts and chest don't ultimately feel
me enough to be a respectable answer it
seems we want to be loved for something
closer to our real self perhaps our soul
or our brain now let's push the thought
experiment further what bit of the brain
is actually most crucial to being me
let's imagine that I have a bump to the
head and lose my ability to play table
tennis am I still myself most of us
would say yes sure what if I once spoke
Latin and lose the ability or forgot how
to cook asparagus with a light
mayonnaise sauce would I still be me yes
in other words technical capacities
don't feel very close to the core of
personal identity what about other kinds
of memories a big part of making me me
tends to be my store of memories I
remember the carpet in my bedroom when I
was growing up or the girl I was in love
with at university or the weather over
Sydney as we came into land for my first
Australian book tour but what if these
memories all vanished as well could I
still be me
one view is possibly so long as
something else remained and that thing
we can call my character in other words
if my characteristic way of responding
to situations my sense of what is funny
wise interesting or important remain the
same I can still in some fundamental way
claim to be the same person
my memories store of feelings and
behaviors might be gone but I could be
assured of continuing to feel and behave
in compatible ways in the future those
around me would need to keep reminding
me of stuff that had happened but they
would still in recognize me as me a
fascinating idea comes into view
personal identity seems to consist not
in bodily survival I could be put in
somebody else's body or live in a jar
and still be me nor in the survival of
memory I could forget everything and
still be me but in the survival of what
we're here going to call character this
is an idea attributed to the English
philosopher John Locke who famously
wrote personal identity is made up of
what he called sameness of consciousness
if a demon offered us a choice between
remembering everything but feeling and
valuing very differently or feeling and
valuing the same sorts of things but
remembering nothing most of us would
Locke suggests choose the latter
so if we have to boil personal identity
down to its essence it seems to come
down to values inclinations and
temperament let's think of death with
all this in mind the standard view of
death is that it's sad because it means
the end of our identity now it certainly
does mean the end if we identify
identity with the survival of our bodies
or with that of our memories but if we
think that who we are is to a large
degree about our values and
characteristic loves and hates then we
are in a sense granted a kind of
immortality simply through the fact that
these will continue to live on in our
species as a whole lodged here and there
outside of
a present home perhaps what we have
learned to call me was only ever a
temporary resting place for a set of
ideas and proclivities that are far
older and are destined to live on far
longer than our bodies we might attempt
to be less sad about death by letting go
of the idea that we are a particular
constellation of physical features we
are always in a sense far longer lasting
far more transgenerational as a bundle
of inclinations and ideas we will
continue to crop up and live wherever
those ideas that are most characteristic
of us will emerge as they must in the
generations that are to come
focusing in on questions of identity has
the paradoxical and rather cheering
effect of making us both less attached
to certain bits of us and more confident
that the really important things about
who we have been will survive in a way
long after our bodies have returned to
dust and our memories have been
obliterated
you